messagers de la paix amis des animaux
sans françois d'assise fait partie des
saints catholiques les plus connus pour
son 20e anniversaire l'église saint
pierre dulac consacre une exposition à
ce religieux
l'occasion de découvrir sa vie au
travers des fresques de giotto du xiiie
siècle
c'est un homme qui aujourd'hui encore
marc des chrétiens des non-chrétiens par
son message de paix par son message
aussi d'harmonie entre l'homme la nature
la création dans son ensemble c'est un
homme qui a beaucoup fait avancer
l'église vers une plus grande vérité de
l'évangile et c'est pas par hasard si le
pape actuel a décidé de s'appeler
françois c'est à cause de saint françois
c'est parce que comme saint françois il
ne voulait une église pauvres pour les
pauvres 28 reproductions photographiques
illustre les épisodes emblématique des
miracles comme le dialogue avec les
oiseaux aux discussions avec le sultan
d'égypte l'une d'elles évoque la rupture
de saint françois avec son père riche
marchand d'assises pour montrer à quel
point il veut se libérer de tout cet
héritage familial il se met
littéralement tenue sur la place
centrale d'assises rendant ses vêtements
à son père pour montrer sa volonté de
liberté totale par rapport aux biens
pour compléter cette présentation
l'église accueillera jusqu'au 25
septembre un manteau authentique ayant
appartenu à saint françois d'assise une
première dans les yvelines